-Dwayne, Jungle Cruise is pretty
legendary as far as rides go.
Or any Disney fan knows.
I might have been --
I might be wrong.
Was it the first ride
that he did
or the first attraction he did,
or no?
-Yes. Yes, you know
your history very well.
In 1955, when Disneyland opened,
Jungle Cruise was
Walt Disney's baby.
-Yeah.
-And he wanted to create a ride,
an experience for people
that they could experience what
it's like around the world,
on the Amazon,
and for those families
who weren't able
to travel the world.
So Jungle Cruise
was Walt's baby.
And as a matter of fact,
here's some cool history.
The very first Jungle Cruise
skipper, in 1955,
when the park opened,
unbeknownst to a lot of fans
who went that day,
was Walt Disney himself.
-No way!
[ Audience oohs ]
-Yeah.
-That's wild.
And that's who you play
in the movie.
I mean, you don't play Walt
Disney, but you're the skipper.
[ Laughter ]
-I was so excited about this.
And honestly I had one --
I had one human being in mind
to be my co-star, and that was
always Emily Blunt.
-Really? Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys --
I can't wait to see this,
but you guys spent, obviously --
She's super funny as well.
-She is.
-I know she has a great
sense of humor. Yeah.
-She's super talented.
She's a multi-threat.
And we became great friends.
I love her. I love her family.
John, their kids.
We're all one big ohana, as we
like to say on the islands.
And I can't wait for everybody
to see her in this movie
because she truly is
the female version of --
and this is saying a lot --
but she truly is the female
version of Indiana Jones.
I'm very proud of her
and how much she kicks ass
in this movie.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dwayne Johnson and
Emily Blunt in "Jungle Cruise."
Take a look at this.
-Come on. I got your pants.
Trust me.
Hold on!
-[ Screams ]
♪♪
Frank. Frank, get it.
-Hold on.
-Come on.
Frank, please.
-I got it.
-Frank!
-I don't got it.
♪♪
-Frank, get off me!
What are you doing?
-I'm trying to get traction.
-This is ridiculous!
-Oh, no. Wait.
-Just leave me alone.
That was a disaster.
-You're too heavy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on! That's a movie.
That's what I want to see.
Dwayne Johnson, everybody!
"Jungle Cruise" is in theaters
and on Disney+
with Premier Access July 30th.